[music]
>> Hi everyone. As you heard, I'm Ben from
Hugging Face and the talk that I'm going
to present to you today is called your
coding agent should do AI systems
engineering.
So, there are two main takeaways that I
want you to get from this talk.
One, and probably the fun part, is that
we can use coding agents to tackle the
hardest engineering problems in AI, so
systems engineering and machine learning
engineering. And maybe the boring part
is that in order to do this, we're going
to need standard repos and we're going
to need those on the hub. And in many
cases, we already have them.
So, I think in this case, I'm preaching
to the choir here, but in case you
haven't noticed, coding agents have been
accepted. Many of of the of us have been
using them for a few years, but in the
last few months, it seems to have
crossed a sort of acceptance gradient
where a
broader group of people are using them.
So, with this in mind, how do we keep
our careers, our engineering kind of
contemporary and how do we keep
challenging ourselves in new areas? And
my proposal is that we need to go kind
of closer to the silicon and tackle
harder problems.
And and that's where AI systems
engineering comes in.
I've broken this talk down into three
progressively
more complex steps and more autonomous
steps as well. And I've defined those
like three bosses from games.
The first one is a hybrid approach where
you interactively use an agent to solve
a
to write a CUDA kernel.
The second is a zero-shot task where an
agent takes a prompt and trains an LLM
on Hugging Face. The third is a
multi-agent auto research setup, like a
kind of automated AI lab.
So, let's get started on on the first
boss, right? This is writing CUDA
kernels.
So, for a while, writing custom kernels
was seen as this unattainable goal for
the humble agent.
They required complex DSLs, they
required integration with relevant
hardware to be benchmarked and to be
tested, and it was seen as something
that couldn't be achieved by agents.
However, that in most cases was wrong.
If you look at
kernel hackathons
like those on GPU mode, the recent AMD
hackathon, if you look at papers like
kernel bench, you'll see that agents are
able to write valid and optimized CUDA
kernels.
And and that's really cool and something
that totally inspires me. I'm a part of
GPU mode, I contribute to that, and and
something that I think everyone should
be doing.
However, what do we do with them? How do
we distribute them and how do we get
them into our inference engine so that
we actually are using these optimized
kernels that we're generating?
And that's part of the question of this
part of the talk.
Let's take a step back now and just
say what a kernel is, right? So, when
you run an AI model on a GPU, the actual
work is executed through a kernel. This
will be defined in a relevant language
for that hardware and it will use
relevant features to that hardware that
may not be available on other hardware.
We can write custom kernels that will
take advantage of that hardware for a
specific math operation, kind of squeeze
everything we can out of it so that the
model will infer faster.
In general, this requires a lot of
expertise about writing CUDA kernels,
about the hardware,
and it's also a bit of an installation
hell as you deal with a pretty large
install matrix from hardware to software
to generations and versions of say CUDA
and these kind of issues. So,
in short, it's hard.
Efficiency in deep learning, so
efficiency in kernels, is split into
three main sections. One, compute, two,
memory, and three, overhead.
Compute is the flops. This is These are
the matrix multiplications and the the
real math of the process. Memory is the
time spent moving data or tensors around
memory, typically from slow to fast
memory. And overhead is basically
everything else, the Python environment,
PyTorch dispatch of those kernels, these
kinds of things.
In general, most people might assume
that the compute is the bottleneck here
because it's doing most of the math,
right?
That's not correct. So, in most cases,
memory is usually the bottleneck. And
that's because a modern GPU, let's take
a H100 for example, can do a petaflop a
second of computation, but its memory
bandwidth is 3 terabytes. So, in short,
the GPU is often waiting idle for this
tensors to come back for it for them to
be computed.
There are custom kernels, custom
optimized kernels that exist. Flash
attention being the poster child of
these. And in general, what they do is
increase arithmetic intensity. They
basically make the GPU do more sums at
once per read and write. So, we move the
tensors across, we do as much math as
possible in the GPU in one go, and then
we write it back. In short, people like
to say we keep the GPUs warm.
And that's the objective of writing a
custom CUDA kernel.
Hugging Face has a library called
kernels, which is maintained by kernel
writers, and we're beginning to scale up
to a kind of agentic workloads. So, at
its core, this is a way of distributing
kernels. It has a toml file like any
kind of project, which says which
hardware it works on, which versions of
CUDA and other kind of softwares it
requires to work. And it's a it's now
also a repo on the hub, just like
models. So, if you are a kernel writer
or you're an aspiring kernel writer with
an agent that you want to set up, you
can now be a kernel publisher, just like
a model publisher.
And my point is that this is like a kind
of super fervent ground for
AI engineers looking to kind of scale
their career.
If you check out these repos on the hub,
you'll see that there's compatibility
for different hardware. You can
configure that so you know, like, okay,
this works on my GPU or on my laptop.
And this is what it looks like here.
Right, let's take a look at what this
looks like for an agent and how we're
helping an agent to do this. So,
first, we're going to go to how we do
this, so skills.
So, I'm sure everyone here is familiar
with skills and and I'm sure there've
been a number of talks that really go
deep into skills.
I don't like to I like to keep them
pretty simple and and really they're
just kind of file-based context. With
all the wonders of files, we can open
them and close them, we can version
them, we can source control them, and
these kinds of things. And agents can
also do the same. They can open them
when they need them, they can use them
when they don't. And so, in the context
of kernels, that means that we can give
examples of how to write and how to use
kernels in skills and they can open
those and use them when they need. I
like to say that it takes a task from
being zero-shot to being few-shot, which
in ML is quite a familiar concept,
right? We're just giving the agent
examples of how to do things.
And we can be quite verbose and
descriptive about that.
At Hugging Face, we're focusing on
integrating skills into their projects.
So, what you'll find is that inside each
project, there's
managed skills by that project, which we
think is the best way to do this because
it means that those projects
that the maintainers of those projects
are maintaining their skills, right?
That means that they're not necessarily
the most like YOLO skills because
they're kind of like well-maintained and
robust. And we have another repo for
those kind of more experimental skills,
which is called Hugging Face skills. Go
and check that out if you want to try
some of these examples you'll see today.
In kernels, this is what the skill looks
like. It focuses on benchmarking, so it
has scripts that allow you to
benchmark and test the skill, sorry, to
test the kernel and see how performant
it is, and references with examples of
how to do this.
We benchmark this skill and we
used we generated a a kernel for Qwen 3
8B for H100, and we found that we had a
94% speedup. This isn't a state of the
art speedup on this model by any means.
It's really just about compatibility and
a compatibility matrix. So, in many
cases, these models and their kernels
won't be optimized for the respective
hardware or generation of hardware that
you want to use them on. So, you have
some low-hanging fruit here where you
can just come and pick up some some
optimizations for that specific
hardware. Maybe because your hardware's
cheap on your cloud provider,
but it's not necessarily the most ideal
for the for that model that you're
using. So, my recommendation would be to
come here and like pick up some easy
speedups.
How do we know that these skills are any
good and and and that we should be
sharing them and telling people to use
them? We use an open source library
called upskill that we're also
maintaining.
This is a is a gateway to using cheaper
and open models with skills.
It basically just generates skills,
generates an eval for the skill, and
then allows you to compare different
models on the same skill. So, you can
see things like this. So, okay, GPT-OSS
is slightly less accurate using the same
tokens. Kimmy is more accurate and using
less tokens. Haiku is a bit more
accurate using less tokens, and these
kinds of things. So, if you've got a
skill and you're using it regularly and
you're thinking to yourself, okay, how
can I save a few pennies here and and
get a different model on the go, then
try out upskill and it allow you to
iterate on your skill and and improve
it.
Right, let's move on to boss two. I'm
going to go through this one pretty
quickly. This is about fine-tuning
models. If you're really into this,
there was a talk yesterday by my
colleague Merve that went into this
deeply. There's also a blog post here
where we got Claude to do this. This was
from back in November-December time now.
Go and check this out. Basically, you
can just say fine-tune Qwen 3 6B on this
dataset. This is a chain of thoughts
dataset. And you'll improve the model's
chain of thoughts. This is fully
integrated to the hub now, so you can
even run the GPUs on on the hub and it
uses HF CLI skills, so it's all very
available. I would try this one out. You
can also try this one out. This is uses
Onslaught, so it's even cheaper. This
runs with like optimized models, and
it's maintained by Onslaught and by us,
and it's another blog post, and there's
also often free credits that you can get
around these blog posts. So, I go and
check these out.
Okay, let's move on to the the big one.
Uh this is
AutoLab multi-agent research, which is a
project that kind of
basically keeps me up at night.
Andre Karpathy a few weeks ago, maybe a
month ago now, released a project called
Auto Research, which was based on his
other projects,
nanoGPT and nanochat, and it took the
nanoGPT architecture and got Claude code
to create improve to write improvements
to that training script so that it would
improve the training process. So, we can
see here the experiments going over, and
then for each experiment there's a
change in the training script, which
increases the efficiency measured in
bits per bytes of that run. And we can
see that the efficiency ends at its best
at the end of the process. I, like
everyone, thought this was super cool,
and I had to start implementing it
straight away. But one of the things
that stood out to me was I like found it
kind of weird that we had one agent
working in a single way, iterating,
going, finding improvements, and then
implementing them. And it would make
sense to kind of distribute this.
So, that's what I did. I distributed the
task amongst the research team with four
types. We have a researcher that
basically looks up papers. For this we
use HF papers, but we can also use
archive papers. HF papers is cool
because it has a CLI, so you can just
pull and search papers from the hub, and
it acts as a lit literature scout. So,
it just looks up for papers with ideas,
and it formulates those as hypotheses.
We then have a planner, which takes
those hypotheses and maintains like a
queue of jobs.
We then have a set of workers, and they
pick up those hypotheses, and their job
is to implement them
as training scripts. So, in many cases
just like change the architecture or
change a parameter or something. And
then we have a a reporter agent that
goes and monitors all these jobs and
maintains a dashboard that we can use.
So, this is what it looks like. If you
see here that we have
working in a in a GitHub project, right?
So, in a Git project, sorry. And we have
a main branch that we maintain with our
train scripts that we're updating in
each branch, and then like a train
original that we that we keep. And then
we have a data structure in the main
branch that we use to just keep the
scores.
Then we implemented this in open code
for this example, but in the repo, which
you can also go and check out,
they it's also implemented in Codex and
Claude if you want to try those. I also
implemented it in Gastown, but that's
kind of wild west stuff, so I did it as
a separate project. Um but basically it
works
really anywhere because it's more just a
conceptual implementation, right?
And first you have your planner creating
hypotheses, you have your researchers
looking up paper, and then your reporter
picking all of this up, handing to
workers as I said. Those workers
integrate with HF jobs, so they start
these jobs off on the hub that run with
the hardware that they need, and then
they submit these patches that go back.
The reporter operates in Trackio, which
is a an open source dashboard that we
use for all metrics. Trackio is useful
with agents because it uses a completely
open data layer, basically parquet. So,
if you don't want the dashboard or your
agent doesn't want the dashboard for any
reason, it can just get into the parquet
and just do whatever you want. So, if
you need a Gantt chart or some other
visualization, it can just go and and do
that. So, I would say it's like the best
agent dashboard tool because it is
basically just a data store. You know,
it's basically just a data structure.
Okay, so let's first walk through this
now.
So, this is it implemented in open code.
If you don't know open code, you have
like agent configuration. So, in this
one I just set AutoLab, which is the
name of the agent configuration I have.
It has skills. This is the prompt, so it
says like run one autonomous local
research or auto research pass in the
repo using defined roles.
I tell it to use planner
to propose up to first single change
experiments, use reviewer to reject
duplicates or stale ideas. I also tell
it to use like a HF bucket because I
want all of the storage to be in the
same bucket so that I don't have to
upload or download the training scripts
every time.
And then we go and we select one of the
sub agents. There's a nice UI interface
in open code, but it's similar in other
tools.
So, I select the planner, and then
you'll see that the planner receives
this prompt, and it uses a specific
template, which I defined in my
configuration of like it's going to have
current state, it's going to have a
a list of the jobs so far, things that
have worked, which were defined by the
reviewer, current hyper parameters that
it can change. And it's basically just
defining these jobs, which will go on to
the the job list as I mentioned.
We then switch over to a reviewer agent,
which will receive all of these jobs. It
has a similar kind of structure based on
a template,
a reference to where it should be
working from, and the latest score that
it should be using. It gets an overview
of all the failed and successful
experiments, which it will then like use
to base its decisions of what goes into
the next queue on. And it creates this
little table, which we don't really need
to look at. It's really just for the
agents to interact with each other and
to get this information back. To be
honest, that's a little bit of a verbose
example, and we maybe don't need this
many tables, and you could probably trim
that bit down.
But in general, I'd recommend if you
think this is cool, go and try that out
in the repo.
After that, so this agent runs in
parallel, sometimes for hours, and this
is the Trackio dashboard that we use,
and these are all the runs that are
pushed to Trackio. As I said, the main
advantage here is that this is fully
open source, and it's just a data layer.
But we get all of these kinds of
visualizations.
Trackio can also have like events and
warnings, so we can have all of these
events being reported by different
agents, and we can filter those down.
We can also even tie those up to like
notifications, so you can get emails
from Trackio if you want, if like your
agents are kind of going rogue or
something
and you need help. But best of all,
Trackio just has this
like just free-form structure, so you
can just throw tables in that don't
necessarily fit with any other
structure.
And then on the hub side, all of these
jobs are just run inside Hugging Face,
so you can explore those jobs. And in
most cases, you can tell the agents to
use like labels, and you can sort those
labels and review through what they're
doing.
Or you can just look at it like this. As
I mentioned, you can access that
underlying data layer and just create a
Gantt chart because this was a kind of
convenient way to look at what the
agents were doing over time. So, you can
see like this amber agent went off, and
this was the score that it got. But you
could visualize this however you want
because you have access to this data
layer.
The kind of TLDR of the whole thing is
that, yeah, you can go and just have
your kind of own AI lab, and you can try
it out. And if you have a verifiable
experiment like training a model or
doing
or writing CUDA kernels, then it is
pretty easy to to implement and set up
and and to learn some stuff.
So, let's now look at the the takeaways
I'd say.
So, the in in simple terms, I'd say that
agents work really well with primitives
and and open primitives, and we want
tools that are fully open, things like
Trackio, things like kernels that we can
expose to agents and they can kind of
control in their own way. Even though
abstracted APIs are really useful, if we
have a layer that we can't necessarily
get behind, that that is a ceiling.
So, we don't always need to extract.
It's more about exposing well.
And the other takeaway is that the hub
is is ready. The Hugging Face hub is
ready for these kind of workloads. We
have the the fundamentals in place like
storage, tracking, and compute, which I
think will allow us to scale our
engineering to, yeah, new levels.
If you found any of this interesting,
I've shared it all on X, I've shared it
all on Hugging Face, and you there's a
blog post about basically each one of
the examples that I just shared with
you, and they all have repos attached to
them, so you can go and try that out for
yourself. If you find anything that's
broken, like please tell me off. If you
think that this was completely wrong,
come and find me afterwards and and sort
of bully me, and that's fine. Uh but
most of all, thank you.
>> [applause]